There are a number of reasons why you
might want to automate or script
different processes. One of these would
be that you don't have to be there when
it's performing this task. You don't
have to watch log files going by. You
don't have to wait for an event to
occur. You simply have the script
provide all of that automation. And this
is often very useful for identifying
problems before they become a much
bigger issue. You can have the script
constantly watch for problems to start
smoldering and then you can stop it
before it turns into a full-blown fire.
The scripts are also much faster than
you are. They are running as fast as
your computer can run, which means they
don't wait for you to type anything in
for input, and there's nothing that you
would have to do to make that script
operate. And there are probably tasks
that you're performing that are
repetitious and mundane. This would be a
perfect use of a script and that would
leave you with more time to perform more
important functions.
Scripts are very good at restarting
computers. We're certainly familiar with
the process. When we run into a problem
with Windows, it's very common to turn
everything off and then back on again to
try to resolve the problem. But why
would you want to use that as part of a
script? Well, you probably performed an
application update and the only way for
that application update to take effect
is to restart a system. But if that
server is in a different data center
that's located in another country, you
might want to have a script perform that
reboot process. Security patches often
require a restart of a system. So, you
can deploy these patches at night while
you're sleeping and have all of these
systems automatically reboot during the
evening. And then when everybody comes
in in the morning, their systems are
ready to go. And this may be a reboot
process that you implement to run at
different times of the day. I was
working with some software that had a
memory leak and after 3 or 4 hours, that
software would stop working and hang the
entire system. But if I rebooted every 2
hours, we would start with a completely
clean slate, and I would never have that
memory leak use up all of the RAM in my
system and cause the system to hang.
When users start up their computer, they
like to have all of the resources they
need available to them inside of the
operating system. And one way that we
can automate the process of connecting
an individual's computer to all of their
necessary resources and file shares is
by using a login script. During the
login process, a user's login script
will connect to all of the necessary
shared drives that they would commonly
use throughout the day. We could also
have this automated mapping function of
network drives built into an upgrade
program. To run the upgrade, the script
connects to the repository containing
all of the upgrade files. It runs those
upgrade files against the existing
system and then at the end of the
script, it disconnects from that
repository. You might also automate this
connection and disconnection of shared
files with a process that backs up user
documents. So, we might connect to the
backup drive, transfer all of the user
documents, and then disconnect from the
backup drive as part of that script.
If you need to upgrade an application,
you could certainly sit at your screen,
watch the upgrade prompts, click okay,
add any other additional information it
needs, and manually step through the
entire upgrade process. Or you could
write a script that does all of this for
you. And if this is in a script, you can
connect it to a login process or you can
have the users start the script
themselves to upgrade the applications
that they need. Upgrading an application
is a common task for any IT environment.
You would usually have a process that
maps the application installation drive.
The script then installs the application
and maybe includes the information that
normally would be manually typed in. It
would then disconnect that drive and
then restart the system. all automated
within the same script.
In this course, you've constantly heard
us talk about the importance of having
good backups. And scripting is a great
way to make sure these backups take
place either at night or during some
type of off hours. We also have to
consider that backups tend to take quite
a bit of time. We're transferring a lot
of information from one system to
another, and we're using quite a number
of network resources during those
backups. So instead of doing this during
the day, we set a script to begin the
backup process at 1:00 in the morning.
It happens while you're sleeping and
when you come in in the morning, your
users have the normal system in front of
them. But in the meantime, you've now
created an entire set of backups.
In it, we have a number of methods that
we use to monitor all of the systems
that are in our infrastructure and
provide reports, alarms, and alerts
about how those systems are performing.
We can use scripting to be able to
automate this process so that the
monitoring happens behind the scenes and
we might even be able to solve problems
automatically using our scripts. For
example, we might have a very important
database server that we need to make
sure is always up and running. So we
might want to monitor CPU usage, memory
utilization, and the amount of network
traffic to and from that device. You can
automate that entire monitoring process
using SNMP built-in monitoring functions
or other third-party monitoring tools.
Some organizations will have a script
that goes out to all of the systems
logged on to the network and perform an
automated inventory of the hardware and
software of that system. This is a very
easy way to keep your inventory database
up to date and you don't have to perform
any of this process manually. And many
organizations will perform automated
vulnerability checks throughout the day.
They'll run automated vulnerability
scanners that are checking operating
systems and applications to ensure that
they are running the latest version of
those apps. And they check to see if
there's any known vulnerabilities that
could be a security concern. And if the
script does find that an application or
operating system needs to be updated, we
can then run the update script for that
specific resource.
Updates are a constant task in
information technology and you will
constantly receive updates about
operating systems that need new features
or that need to push out security
patches or maybe there are new device
drivers for the hardware that you're
using so that you get rid of any bugs
that may be associated with the old
drivers or perhaps include new features
that may be included with the latest set
of device drivers. And of course, when a
new application is available, we can
create a script to be able to push that
application out automatically with no
user intervention.
Of course, scripting is not a panacea.
There are still best practices that we
have to consider. And we have to also be
aware of problems that could occur
during the scripting process. For
example, if we're installing new
software, we might want to make sure
that that software is not already
infected with some type of malware.
Otherwise, we would be distributing this
new software to all of these systems
automatically and effectively automating
the malware distribution process to all
of these systems. You might also create
a script that makes changes to a system
registry. Normally, this is something
that you can easily test and confirm
that it doesn't affect any other part of
the system. But occasionally, you might
find that the change that you've made
affects other applications and other
resources on the network. So, it's
always a good idea to perform as much
testing as possible, but it's also a
good idea to have a script that allows
you to roll back if that change doesn't
work. These scripts are obviously only
performing the tasks that you asked them
to perform. And if there is any syntax
error, any issue with the information
that you've added to the script, or
maybe it's just a loose character that
slipped into the script somewhere, you
could create a problem with the script
running. or in worst case you create
problems with the systems that are
running the script themselves. It's very
easy to create outages and downtime by
using scripts that have inadvertent
information inside of the script itself.
Your best practice is to always back up
information, perhaps even as part of the
script and to always perform as much
testing as possible to confirm that
there will not be any problems when you
start running this script in production.